all right so Creed 3 is punching its way
into theaters with Adonis returning for
the main event going Toe to Toe with a
ghost from his past the Kang gang wait
that's actually um never never mind but
yeah these Creed flicks have really
landed for me and this third ramps
things up even more so in this video
we're gonna be breaking this thing down
for y'all what the ending means for
creed where the heck was Rocky potential
spin-offs and of course our reaction and
review for this Haymaker flying hadouken
Style movie all sorts of heavy spoilers
in This heavyweight matchup so a huge
thank you for clicking this I'm your
featherweight host Jared put up your
dukes and let's get into Creed Three
just start fighting
all right so Creed 3 picks up years
after the events of Creed 2 with Adonis
now comfortably living the retired life
career-wise and being more of a family
man he hasn't boxed in the ring for
roughly three years taking a page from
Rocky 3 kind of instead focusing on
training the best up and coming boxers
in his gym and setting up the biggest
prize fights however as these things go
a ghost from his past appears at his
doorstep stirring up old forgotten
memories Damien Dame Anderson played by
Jonathan Majors is that ghost back in
the day both lived in a boy's home
together with Damien being an
up-and-comer in the amateur boxing
leagues but after a night of the two
hanging out Adonis assaults an old boy's
home guardian that abused him Damien
then pulls a gun with Adonis running
away resulting in Damien taking the Heat
and going to prison for 18 years now all
of this past coming back to haunt them
slash Underdog Revenge story leads the
pair to face off against one another in
a huge prize fight at Dodger Stadium but
not before Adonis gives Damien a second
chance training at his gym for free
becoming a sparring partner with Creed's
prized Felix Chavez the reigning
heavyweight champ of the world however
all of this was a part of Dame's plan
orchestrating an assault on Victor Drago
who was supposed to fight Chavez taking
his place in the event due to an urgent
scheduling conflict beating him
mercilessly in the ring and becoming the
heavyweight champ basically overnight
classic nepotism Creed knows he must
right his wrong so he retires from
retirement jumping back into the ring
publicly challenging Dame for the title
now the whole story especially the
ending deals with past trauma regrets
grudges fractured relationships living
in the past needing to overcome those
barriers and forgiveness Creed is
dealing with the haunt team memory of
that night long ago Damien essentially
using him and his mother who hid letters
Damien had written Creed all of those
years ago very the notebookish but one
of the most emotional scenes is Creed's
mother passing due to a stroke but even
she goes as far as to forgive Apollo and
Adonis in her last moments which drives
Creed to do the same as for Damien he is
dealing with the fact that his life and
dream was robbed from him and even
though he doesn't know Creed never
received his letters he holds that
against him in their final bout with one
another the final climactic 12 round
boxing match is different from your
stereotypical boxing matches in movies
because Jordan uses some of his anime
influences here to Showcase how yes this
is a fight amongst two behemoths but
also each is fighting their own internal
problems and struggles a moment where
prison bars are on the side of the ring
is the struggle Damien endured while
visualizing it for Creed the same goes
for creed when punching Damien he
visualizes him as a pillow which was
something tied to the boy's home where
he was abused as a child so it's really
interesting the way Jordan was able to
frame this final fight as several
different things allowing it to become
personal for each character Creed
essentially gets a second third ninth
wind thinking of his mother knocking out
Damien with less than a minute left in
the 12th round Creed goes on to become
the reigning heavyweight champ once
again in the peak of boxing so not too
surprising for this Underdog type story
but the ending honestly feels like the
deleted scene from Creed 2 where Creed
talks with a Victor in the locker room
it may not seem like it now but but you
gotta know you more than just one fight
we both are
of course this time it is Creed and
Damien in these positions with the two
forgiving one another for everything
that they had gone through it's a much
earned final scene for the pair calm and
emotional and sets up Damien as someone
who could make a return in the franchise
as kind of a frenemy now does Creed 3
feature any sort of post-credit scene
tease towards what's next for the champ
like the street fighters block a jump
out Electrify Creed and break apart his
car and no not exactly but at the
Hollywood premiere of Creed 3 Michael B
Jordan did hint at potentially more
Creed movies or even spin-offs saying
building the Creed universe is something
that I'm really excited about so it's no
surprise B Jordan wants Creed to be what
Rocky was so I could see Creed 4 having
him back in the Limelight his stock
higher than ever but with a bigger
Target on his back even going
International with the scope of things
and the anime influences of the villains
and fight choreography maybe not as far
as the street fights of Rocky 5 and
Tommy Gun but you see where I'm coming
from and with the mention of a bigger
Creed Universe this all ties in with
reports of a Drago movie in the works
reported exclusively by the rap
screenwriter Robert Lawton had been
tapped to write Drago focusing on the
Drago family both Ivan and Victor
unfortunately no further details have
been revealed so I could see this
picking up on the character current day
in terms of the Creed franchise but
peppering in flashbacks to show some of
his Origins and struggles without fully
diving into another stereotypical
Hollywood origin story I'm curious if
you'd want to see this Rocky and Creed
franchise blow out and get weird with
all of these different boxers if so drop
your best anime video game-esque
character for Creed To Face Off against
in the comments mine would be ethelbert
P Shackleton the third fighting only in
the Old English boxing style brilliant
brilliant now one of the biggest
absences from the film was good old
Rocky hey Rocky where you at Stallone is
nowhere to be seen his name is mentioned
in passing a couple of times while some
scenes definitely feel like they needed
his presence however the story never
fully gives the audience an explanation
of where he's at his status really
anything well it's a bit of a messy
behind the scenes reason why the creator
of this character and franchise isn't
here now quick story time but back when
Stallone was trying to get Rocky off of
the ground he ended up selling the
ownership rights to the producer Erwin
Winkler because at the time Stallone
only had a hundred dollars to his name
and basically needed this to survive now
fast forward almost five decades
Stallone still has zero ownership of a
character or franchise and was a bit
caught off guard when he heard news of
the Drago spin-off Colleen Winkler a
parasite who is picking clean the bones
of another wonderful character I created
in a recent interview with Sirius XM
Stallone shared that he's had a rough
emotional ride in choosing to cut ties
with the franchise that he created do
you have like do you feel like I can
never watch Creed 3 kind of thing never
but that he refuses to support any new
Creed movies as long as producer Erwin
Winkler is still involved you can't make
peace when someone has been so nefarious
in my in my opinion so like horrible now
if Michael B Jordan we come up a story
I'll do Creed 4 with him as long as the
other fellow is not involved right so
who knows maybe if and or when Creed 4
comes around Rocky will make his
long-awaited return up those
Philadelphia Museum of Art stairs with
everyone cheering but yeah yeah I had a
solid time with Creed 3. sure is it
predictable with the story beats jumping
to exactly what and where you thought
they were going yeah kinda but I don't
think that this needed a deep
introspective look on the character
though it does crack into some great
symbolism and subtext of past trauma
regrets grudges fractured relationships
and living in the past in the final
fight between Creed and Dom with the
final fight being something totally new
Fantastical leaning into the anime
influences Jordan wanted to Showcase
here and honestly that worked for me it
feels like it has its own style and
identity thanks to Michael B Jordan's
directorial debut Vision but is a bit
more than just another boxy movie it has
a Sprinkle of a Revenge Thriller
mirroring elements of 2015's the gift
with Jonathan Majors absolutely nailing
the dramatic scenes and being a complete
monster in the physical scenes my
scorecard at the end of 12 rounds would
be a 7 out of 10 for creed 3. it's got
the stuff Rocky and Creed fans are
looking for and there's enough evolution
in the fight choreography to make it
feel fresh like some really cool slow
down analyzing and targeting body parts
that feels video game-esque but I
thought that there were some really
obvious pacing issues between Acts 2 and
3 hoping for more bombastic boxing and
honestly Rocky was definitely missed in
the emotional scenes after Creed's
mother passed away Rocky didn't need a
huge role but he was missed also you
know in like Creed 6 or whatever his
daughter is going to carry on the mantle
it's right there so like in 12 years let
me know I'm right anyway I'd love to
hear your thoughts on Creed 3 was this
another solid addition into the Rocky
and Creed world and what did you think
of B Jordan's directorial debut and I'll
let you know we're currently running the
competition giving away three three
copies of the rocky 4K box set on the
15th of March it's only right for this
movie and all you got to do to get a
chance of winning this is like this
video subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment down below with your
thoughts of creed 3. we picked the
comments at random at the end of every
single month and the winners of last
month are on screen right now so if
that's you message us on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch be sure to check out some
of our other cool videos right over
there look at them there's so many
videos click one of them but with all of
that out of the way thank you for your
constant support I've been Jared I'll
see in the next one take care and peace